Elon Musk is the world's richest man
he's also the founder and CEO of SpaceX
Tesla and many other great companies but
whenever he speaks about the economy for
some reason everyone starts to pay
attention he just sent out an email to
all the executives at Tesla and he said
that he's got a super bad feeling about
the economy and that Tesla is going to
slash about 10 percent of their employee
base now Tesla's a fascinating company
they had about a hundred thousand
employees at the end of last year and
they're gonna cut 10 of all those jobs
10 000 people are about to lose their
job now Elon this isn't the first time
that he's actually talked about some
kind of super bad feeling about the
recession his General argument is that
there's been money rained on fools and
they've been doing all kinds of dumb
things with it the market got frothy
people were doing insane things and of
course a recession is important his
whole idea is that there needs to be
bankruptcies there needs to be a
cleansing of the economy and bad
companies need to go out of business
Capital needs to get reallocated to the
good companies and then after we get
that correction we can go back to the
good times now of course as Elon Musk
speaks it's one thing to hear what he's
saying but it's another thing to see
what he's doing and that's exactly what
people are paying attention to as this
email goes out to those Tesla Executives
saying we're gonna pause all hiring
we're gonna fire 10 of the staff and I
got a super bad feeling about the
economy whenever somebody who's got this
amount of wealth and this much
information they must be looking at all
of their supply chain data all their
financial data and of course paying
attention to their employee base
whenever they start to warn about this
type of recession looming you should
start paying attention he's not the only
one we've seen Jamie Diamond and a
number of others all talk about an
economic hurricane that's on the horizon
again maybe it comes or maybe it doesn't
but if you're unprepared that's when
disasters happen and so to see Elon Musk
simply saying hey you know what we
should do we probably should pause
hiring new people maybe we should cut 10
of our Workforce and we should be
prepared for a bad situation I don't
think it's that crazy and actually I
would even argue that this means that
Elon is being prudent he understands
future risk and he's trying to mitigate
it the best CEOs in the world they're
risk killers they don't want to sit
there and have an unexpected economic
problem instead they're prepared and if
Tesla ends up actually navigating this
well they may come out stronger on the
shot be fascinating to watch how this
plays out recessions aren't fun seems
like Elon thinks that we're headed
towards one